il 23 maggio 2007 è stata una data molto
importante per la storia dell'umanità
perché ha segnato il sorpasso della
città sulla campagna come numero di
abitanti
lo spazio urbano è diventato un
laboratorio interessante in cui
osservare le trasformazioni politiche
economiche e sociali che stiamo vivendo
le città contengono tanti piccoli
microcosmi in cui è possibile apprezzare
le contrapposizioni tra aree di povertà
e aree ricche e in cui si sviluppano i
processi di individualizzazione a cui
spesso siamo esposti non conoscere il
nostro vicino di casa e non avere una
vita di quartiere sono soltanto due
degli esempi delle forme di isolamento
che stiamo vivendo la geografia delle
città ci dice molto delle enormi
trasformazioni di oggi i cambiamenti dei
metodi produttivi e un sistema di
sviluppo basato su servizi cultura e
turismo trovano molte manifestazioni
fisiche nelle nostre città
avete notato quanti impianti industriali
oggi non sono piu in funzione e restano
abbandonati o pensate a quante caserme
nei centri delle nostre città sono oggi
dismesse inutilizzate
perché la fine della guerra fredda e la
nascita dell'unione europea hanno
modificato le nostre esigenze di difesa
nazionale
la crisi economica poi i tagli alla
spesa pubblica hanno reso difficile per
molte amministrazioni curare il verde
pubblico con il risultato che molte
aiuole e aree cani somigliano a delle
piccole giungle urbane la città insomma
può essere un luogo di abbandoni aree
inutilizzate abbandonate edifici in
cerca di una seconda destinazione negli
ultimi anni giuristi e pianificatori
urbani è stato a definire questi spazi
beni comuni urbani un'espressione
e ci consente di mettere in evidenza
almeno tre elementi primo questi spazi
così come tutte le risorse di proprietà
pubblica
appartengono a tutti e tutte noi questo
vuol dire che lo stato le regioni e
comuni devono soltanto amministrarli nel
nostro interesse
secondo elemento
questi luoghi possono essere considerati
dalle città come un fardello di cui
liberarsi
oppure come dei luoghi delle opportunità
terzo se questi spazi appartengono a
tutti e tutte noi allora soltanto la
cooperazione sociale può essere il modo
per dare loro una seconda destinazione a
partire da queste osservazioni
negli ultimi anni i beni comuni sono
diventati un importante strumento per
rispondere alla crisi introducendo forme
alternative di lavoro pensate ad esempio
un edificio abbandonato che ospita un
centro servizi in cui dare aiuto a
quanti non sono sufficientemente
supportati dallo stato sociale o
dall'assistenza pubblica o pensate al
lavoro comune e alla cooperazione
sociale per trasformare un'aiola
abbandonata in un orto urbano stefano
rodotà ha scritto che i beni comuni sono
essenziali per lo sviluppo della persona
umana e che tutte e tutti devono avere
accesso al loro uso non si tratta
soltanto dell'acqua o di internet ma
anche di tutti quei luoghi in cui è
possibile ricostruire legami di
solidarietà la strada l'edificio
l'aiuola sono soltanto il punto di
partenza per creare una città più
accogliente e oggi ne abbiamo davvero
tanto bisogna costruire insieme un
progetto nell'interesse di tutti
rappresenta un modo per ricreare insieme
lo spazio urbano e smettere di essere
soltanto dei semplici utenti dei servizi
i beni comuni insomma sono un modo per
sviluppare la condivisione sono un modo
anche per costruire una visione
ecologica della città perché
riutilizziamo gli spazi che ci sono già
non ne costruiamo di nuovi e in questo
modo non consumiamo il nostro suolo
mappare i beni comuni però non è
sufficiente
questi spazi sarebbero vuoti e
inutilizzati
se non ci fosse un gruppo di persone
disponibili a prendersene cura
lavorando insieme impegnandosi per la
loro rigenerazione e per la loro cura
i beni comuni insomma hanno sempre
bisogno di una comunità che li curi il
compito delle città in questo scenario è
quello di assicurare innanzitutto le
condizioni giuridiche e amministrative
per liberare le necessarie energie
molto spesso infatti la cura dei beni
comuni è ostacolata dall assenza di una
legge con il risultato che molte
attività che realizzano bisogni
essenziali sono considerate illegali
nonostante siano pienamente legittime
proprio per evitare questi problemi
negli ultimi anni più di cento città in
italia hanno adottato un regolamento per
facilitare la cooperazione dei cittadini
nella cura dei beni comuni urbani
tra queste città c'è anche torino che è
insieme all'università e ad altri
partner sta sperimentando il suo
regolamento in un progetto che si chiama
così così ti è un progetto che consenta
ai cittadini e all'amministrazione di
disegnare insieme lo spazio urbano la
collaborazione e la co progettazione
sono due elementi essenziali di questo
progetto è in generale della cura dei
beni comuni urbani
questo però non significa né sostituirsi
a un'amministrazione sempre più in crisi
né tantomeno prestare lavoro gratuito
la cura dei beni comuni è un modo di
occuparsi delle città e per questo
costituisce una forma di partecipazione
politica molto concreta i cittadini
hanno la possibilità di creare con le
proprie azioni
lo spazio pubblico urbano l'obiettivo di
così ti è quello di migliorare le nostre
periferie e consentire
l'organizzazione di nuovi centri di
aggregazione in cui economia alternative
legami di solidarietà e processi di
valorizzazione sociale trovano casa
questo è importante perché la
privatizzazione e il fare cassa non sono
gli unici strumenti per uscire dalla
crisi economica la reazione dei
cittadini alle opportunità offerte da
così ti è stata cospicua è molto
interessante più di 140 gruppi e
associazioni hanno presentato un
progetto per prendersi cura degli spazi
urbani dall area cani che ha bisogno di
una panchina in più alla piazza di
quartiere all'edificio abbandonato a una
scuola che oltre l'orario di chiusura è
normalmente sottoutilizzata la
condivisione e quindi al centro
dell'idea di così di creare appunto una
città condivisa per farlo serve il
contributo di tutte e di tutti e non
bisogna certo essere dei professionisti
per dare il proprio contributo
infatti i bisogni di un quartiere e
quelli di una scuola costituiscono la
bussola da seguire per disegnare un
progetto di rigenerazione urbana la
nascita e l'organizzazione di una
comunità trovano nella fiducia reciproca
gli elementi essenziali per costruire
forme di cooperazione sociale usciti da
qui guardatevi attorno registrate gli
edifici abbandonati e le aiole dismesse
immaginate cosa possono diventare come
renderli accessibili invece che
escludenti progettate un progetto che
vada nell'interesse di tutti del resto
gli esempi da cui imparare sono molti ed
esistono già pensate a quante
associazioni nelle nostre città dal
centro alle periferie sviluppano ogni
giorno progetti di cultura indipendente
soddisfano i bisogni del quartiere in
cui si trovano in fin dei conti
occuparsi dei beni comuni urbani
significa riscoprire le nostre comunità
e occuparci
delle nostre unità reclamate il vostro
diritto alla città il diritto cioè a
essere protagonisti attivi dello spazio
pubblico urbano
grazie mille
[Applauso]